[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
Trump's impromptu visit to the DMZ
separating the two Koreas was
unprecedented and historic indeed it was
a bold even brilliant decision of course
his political opponents particularly the
Democrats running for president and the
media slammed Trump's unorthodox
diplomacy who is on the side of peace
[Music]
crosstalking North Korea I'm joined by
my guest ray mcgovern in Raleigh he is a
former CIA analyst and co-founder of
veterans intelligence professionals for
sanity in Jerusalem we have ephraim
inbar he is president of the Jerusalem
Institute for strategy and security and
in Plymouth we cross to Patrick
headington he's the executive editor of
the news website 21st century wire.com
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means he can jump in any
time you want and I always appreciate
let me go to ray first in in Raleigh I
just want to comment I know that you're
growing your beard to give attention to
the maltreatment that Julian Assange is
being is experiencing right now so good
for you my brother Amen for your
protests but let's go to the affairs at
hand here North Korea ray you're an old
handed of international politics Trump
made an unprecedented bold move he's
been slammed left and right and center
for it I think it is brilliant he's
thinking outside the box because with
the policy towards North Korea is over
and over again the same policies are
attempted and they fail now we have a
new start I don't know if it's gonna go
anywhere but it's bold and it's worth
paying attention to
ray in Raleigh it's hard to know for
sure where it's going if anywhere
because Trump has to get rid of Bolton
and and Pompeyo if he wants to achieve
any success or at least remind them
who's president he's got other obstacles
and the main one is what I call the
Mickey Matt the military if you got a
pencil here yeah yeah yeah military
industrial congressional intelligence
media a khadeem think-tank complex
Mickey Matt now why do I say media
because that's a seen acorn on that's
the thing that makes it possible for to
derail everything that Trump wants to
accomplish in terms of reducing tension
because you know the media is owned by
the same corporation of the profits here
and these tensions and Wars so hello you
can't you figure it out so the media has
deceived most of the American people and
thinking that the leader of North Korea
is just you're a beast and it's going to
take a while for Trump and his folks if
they want to do an agreement to correct
that and to say look we can't make them
completely disarmed but at least we can
put in guarantees that they don't want
that they don't do something really bad
and the guarantees will come from
immediate neighbors Russia and China and
that's the big new impetus that's the
big new element and that's where we're
gonna talk about that for sure Efrem let
me go to you in Jerusalem ray brings up
a bring a good point here I was watching
the cable stations and of course the the
way the North Korea and its leader is
characterizes in the worst possible
terms my question is what does it what
difference does it make you want to
reduce tensions on the peninsula
I mean Stalin and Churchill and
Roosevelt worked to defeat fascism in
Europe
no one was singing the praises of Stalin
Soviet Union they wanted to defeat a
common enemy we have a growing coalition
here North Korea is a political fact Kim
is a political fact do you want to have
peace you have to deal with both go
ahead in Jerusalem yeah but North Korea
is indeed affect but not a very pleasant
fact so it is a dictatorship that
possesses nuclear weapons and it's
troublesome for the South Koreans it's
troublesome for Japan the nuclearization
in South Korea may bring about the
nuclearization of South Korea as well as
the nuclearization of Japan a
proliferation of nuclear weapons is not
a good recipe for peace therefore I
think that it's important to try to
denuclearize North Korea I of course
admit that this job is not an easy one
because for the North Korean regime the
nuclear bomb bits is insurance policy so
yeah yeah I'll I'll out first up is
Dylan
I'm from the North Korean saw what the
the West did to Libya so no wonder it
needs an insurance policy Patrick let me
go to you jump in and reflect on what's
already been said here go ahead well
firstly I want to just comment on what
Ephraim said I I don't I don't believe
North Korea they don't have a confirmed
nuclear weapons arsenal this is this is
all up in the air a lot of this
arbitrary analysis according to the CIA
one of multiple assessments from 2010 to
2013 admitted that they are not sure
what exactly they have they have done
tests this seems to have been confirmed
nuclear tests but in terms of
operational warheads it's unknown on top
of that their ICBM program is a bit
ridiculous in comparison to other
countries so we don't know exactly how
far they have achieved in terms of
medium-range long-range missiles okay
they are potentially a threat but South
Korea is not going to acquire a bomb
just because North Korea haven't started
to date they don't need to because the
United States provides that deterrent
they have that in Okinawa they have that
in Guam and they have that in South
Korea and they manage the DMZ so this is
part of the United States is extended
deterrent post-world War two security
agreement and pact with Japan to control
the Pacific but I think what's more
important here is that North Korea
provides the absolute key stone to the
United States Pacific Rim strategy so if
there is peace on the Korean Peninsula
they provide that's the public facing
key stone the back end is China and
everybody knows that but in terms of the
front end how it looks in the public
they're the villain North Korea
Pyongyang is the villain if there's
peace on the Korean Peninsula then you
have a little bit of a problem in terms
of u.s. geostrategy they'll have to
reengineer towards China at that point
because there's no other threat in the
Pacific to basically justify that sort
of extended deterrence which has been
post the post-world War two
strategy for how many
now almost going on nearly 80 years not
long now so you know you know ray though
the if you look at the opponents of
Trump's gambit here and I think I use
the word purposely gambit because it is
very unusual here but the people that
are against this are all comfortable
with the status quo they like they
wanted to remain the same for reasons
that you've already mentioned and
Patricks already mentioned okay I mean
when you think of the resources that are
spent on the military for the for the
Korean Peninsula its vast it's huge
they don't want that market to go away
they want this threat and that's why
they will demonize North Korea to the
nth degree to scare people they they
want this I mean in the media loves war
oh they just love it it's great for
ratings and it's a great way to hate
Donald Trump
go ahead ray well if you look at
Raytheon you look at Lockheed you look
at some of the other big defense
contractors this would be the worst news
that ever happened to have a deal and
Korea maybe even a peace treaty how
could they sell anti-ballistic missiles
being stationed all around ostensibly
against North Korea but really against
China how could they justify these
billions some people say a trillion
dollars on worthless anti-ballistic
missile systems when the Russians have
already proven that they can circumvent
by a by many stratagems these systems so
it doesn't matter if they work or not
it's matter that the people who profits
here on this and these same people
control the media and that's not an
exaggeration to look at look at who
controls the media as long as they
profits here we're gonna have real
disappointment if there's a lessening in
tension not only in the Far East but of
course in Europe and Russia as well okay
let me go back to Jerusalem okay it's
Trump
I took made the first step okay
literally first steps into the DMZ into
North Korea what should his next step be
if he wants this to gain some momentum
go ahead I think that Trump is an
isolationist he would love to get out of
Korea
he would love to to get out of American
commitment to to its allies we all know
how he spoke to the Netta NATO allies
and therefore I think that he wants some
kind of agreement
not necessarily peace you know I don't
know exactly what peace means
independence in the Korean Peninsula he
wants an agreement in order to save
money to the American taxpayer and I
don't worry so much about American
military industries because the main
sweat to in in Asia is rising China and
all countries around China are buying
more and more weapons Israel is one
beneficiary of it and bank accounts of
the military industries in America I
don't worry about them well you know
okay you don't worry about it that's
amazing you say that because there's a
lot of people on the receiving end
profits and death okay Patrick I mean
the interesting thing is essentially the
same question that I asked let me go to
the Patrick fair talk fair of a time for
everyone here is that you know there is
already a plan out there and it's the
Russians and the Chinese that have it I
mean Trump would be very very wise to
embrace it go ahead
Patrick sure sure I mean there's a
number of other issues here wider
geopolitical issues one of them is you
you can't separate the negotiations on
on Korea between the denuclearization
negotiations you can't separate this
with what's going on between the u.s.
and Iran at the moment these two are
inextricably linked and I think what the
United States is trying to do in Donald
Trump administration's art of the deal
sort of way is to try to get some kind
of a winning formula yeah with regards
to North Korea and then some success at
least in the run up through the 2020
elections and then go to the global
public and say look this worked in Korea
we lopped all these preconditions on we
front-loaded the deal we've got a deal
even if they don't get the deal at that
time they can say they've got the deal
and then go to the Iranians and say why
doesn't Iran take this this perfectly
reasonable deal that we can inspect all
of their military facilities Patrick I
have to jump in here we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on North
Korea State with our theme
[Music]
welcome back to cross back where all
things are considered on Peter labelled
Tremonti we're discussing North Korea
[Music]
okay wait let me go back to you in
Raleigh everybody knows this Trump is in
election mode he wants to be reelected
and he wants a win he wants a wind that
he can run on he was smart in staving
off an attack on Iran Bolton should be
fired
and just be shamed out of government
he's just a tapeworm in the in the
borough of bureaucracy but he wants he
wants a victory and and by walking them
into the DMZ he's made it his own is
very very own with Tucker Carlson
watching from the sidelines not John
Bolton exiled into Mongolia so this is
very important for truth it's very
important for Trump can he and you know
government very very well you know how
it works and it doesn't work and you
know how people can become obstacles so
what does Trump need to do to make this
a win or a perceived win and I stress
perceived win go ahead ray well you'll
notice
Peter that tapeworm Bolton was not at
the DMZ now that's not a conclusive
indicator but you know we criminologists
used to look at the top of Lennon's to
him and see who wasn't there okay so
that's a straw in the wind he may get
rid of Bolton he may get rid of Pompeo
now the important thing here is not to
give Trump exclusive rights to this
success I think he was talked to by
Chinese President Z by Russian President
Putin in in Osaka at the g20 and they
tell them look I can understand your
predecessors destroyed Iraq and Libya
because they didn't have a nuclear
weapon case you understand how Kim looks
at this for pete's sake it's a deterrent
now if we can give you some sort of
guarantees and we're really really
engaged because that's right on our
border right now and we don't want some
nukes going off right on the border if
we give you that let's get a deal I
think the Russians and Chinese are as
much responsible for Trump saying
maybe uh maybe I'll ask him to meet me
at the DMZ as Trump himself from the you
know like I've said in the first part of
the program is that there is already a
plan out there I mean it's freeze for
freeze and it's imminent ly doable and
we have to remember to and I think it's
I always lament the fact that South
Korea isn't given enough credit for its
efforts here to bring in a thaw I mean
President moon is brilliant he's really
reads this very very well and Donald
Trump is giving it some momentum so
shouldn't Donald Trump if he wants the
win let everybody else do the heavy
lifting let the Chinese the Russians and
the South Koreans do it go ahead in
Jerusalem I think Trump is already
victorious since he doesn't want a
military victory neither in the Gulf or
Nova the Korean Peninsula he already won
the four pages of every newspaper in the
world he made the first item on every TV
news and he does that all the time okay
this is not an exception okay it's it's
we're all living in trumps world right
now if we like it or not Patrick you're
nodding your head
why uniting your head for go ahead
Patrick b-because on you know continue
on what Efrem said Trump is going to
absolutely stage-managed this process to
maximum effect over the next 18 months
right through the election cycle this is
one of the few areas where he can get a
win you could get potentially a clear
enough win where there's not as many
tertiary problems and issues like you
have with Iran the likelihood that
they're gonna get a win in Iran anytime
soon seems to be slim in none not least
of all because of the allies in the
region of the u.s. that are also
exacerbating that situation namely Saudi
Arabia and Israel but I think in terms
of the election cycle this is going to
be this is going to disarm the
Democratic opposition in many of the
debates as well because
president he habit as the accumbens the
advantage of being able to select the
timing and the symbology of it is gonna
be great
not unlike a Gorbachev or Sadat kind of
moment and yes there were underlying
realities during those two that made a
lot of those outcomes inevitable but
they got the credit for doing this
thinking outside the box or doing the
unpopular thing at the time and coming
out with some good PR from that and I
think Donald Trump has an opportunity to
do that whether they actually get an
agreement or a deal it's neither here
nor there this is the symbolism of it as
our colleagues are previously commented
is what's important and the likelihood
of a shooting more breaking out on the
Korean Peninsula now is so low if you go
to your local bookies and get odds on it
and substantially substantially long
odds now well and that's why I said to
rate I'm going to rate right now
perceived win that's what I said
perceived win and I think we're on the
same page Patrick rate you want to jump
in that's the point of the program go
ahead yeah I think you're exactly right
now I have great respect for my friend
Patrick but I think he's being a little
too prematurely sanguine so to say so to
speak perceived when depends on the
media yep media is all caps in the
Mickey mat okay now the election is a
year and a half away there's all manner
of opportunity for the media helped by
people like Bolton and Pompeyo to
discredit the the president to say he
was naive and to preclude any success in
Korea as they have successfully done
with respect to any success in making a
more decent relationship with Russia
there's nothing no reason why it can't
be done except the media has educated
the American people to believe it can't
be done because poutine and and Kim are
well as Pompeo says demons apparently
Pompeo believes in demons yeah I don't
yeah he really believes in the
apocalypse there that's a really scary
guy Efrem stay with the theme up and
learn something
go ahead ray go ahead ray go ahead yeah
I just wanted to add
learn something hopeful and that is that
I've told Pompeo that there's a weight
limit on the rapture sorry sorry about
that go there from April let's stay with
the media with all due respect I think
that from champion my colleague with all
due respect I think my colleague
exaggerates the power of the media we
shouldn't forget that President Trump
was elected despite the media and it
doesn't matter for Trump if the media
agree the same as long as they put his
picture so you know the New York Times
again it doesn't matter if the New York
Times is is giving him you know
complimentary reviews what is important
is that the name of Trump appears on the
first page and this is what Trump wants
is well yeah as always I know the media
is not I would disagree let me go to
Patrick right now it's because media
determines how people think about an
issue here and and they're at fault for
for looking for the next Hitler in the
world the demonization of regimes and
it's the media that does that and of
course they get talking points from the
deep state but the media gleefully does
this thing and it's against the national
interest and I've gone through all three
of you know I still haven't asked the
question I really want about the media
Patrick I mean when the media does
undermine Trump the perception in the
world is that he is not in control of
his own government he's not in control
of his people around him and the
perception is is that you can't make a
deal with Trump because he'll flip on a
dime you don't know what you're going to
get and and I have to admit you know
going to going into the DMZ again really
unpredictable so he's unpredictable I
can cut both ways Patrick yeah and the
difference is going to be look how the
media treated him during the last
election cycle they're against him the
whole time look at the result arguably
you're not going to have a stronger
candidate than Hillary Clinton this time
around on the Democratic side are and
this is a small margin of victory the
Trump would have to go for but still if
the media is against him
his that will wind his base up to
support him it'll it'll energize the
base whatever Trump does it's gonna
energize the base especially if the
media is against him the
counter-argument from the Democrats is
going to be how could you coddle a
brutal dictator who's guilty of all
these human rights violations and that
argument is gonna fail miserably because
human rights and denuclearization are
nuclear non-proliferation are two
separate issues absolutely never be
placed in the same basket so Trump's
going to win on scale on mass on that
argument so I think if the timing of
rolling out something in August or
September or right after the you know
before the election after the convention
that's going to be a huge advantage on
his part but CNN you know they
introduced North Korea as the Hermit
Kingdom that's what Jake Tapper has
loaded on the teleprompter basically
they totally underestimate the DPRK they
talk about them like they're backward
medieval and they're not they're very
canny they understand the American
propaganda very well as do the Iranians
and I think that's a huge
underestimation on the part of the US
media to keep sort of downplaying Kim
and downplaying the North Korea as the
sort of clueless backward a country
that's not knowledgeable about how
politics runs in the West they
absolutely do yeah let me go back to Ray
I mean you can throw in the tapeworms in
in media too I mean all these people are
low octane thinkers really low octane
thinkers you know they pay them a lot of
money to smile and read glass okay but
they're not thinkers go ahead ray yeah
Peter I throw in robert muller molar and
the media now patrick just mentioned
something very significant and that is
how well the democrats did in the
congressional xions well what was what
was Muller doing then he knew damn well
by then that there was no collusion why
did he say it why did he wait till
several months after the election so the
Democrats could do it really well why
did he wait until later to say well you
know actually I can't find the evidence
collisions so it's not only the media
it's the whole deep state which as you
know I call the Mickey Matt okay Ephraim
I'm gonna give you the last video how
optimistic you are at Trump we'll get
something before the election well I
think if there is a president that
ignores the deep state
it is stomp Trump is so unpredictable he
doesn't listen to his adviser he doesn't
read the intelligence briefings every
morning and he does his own show so you
know the importance of the deep state
Israel but it has less influence on this
president and any other president before
okay well we've seen the deep state trip
we try to trip this president up
repeatedly let's make let's hope that on
this one issue he can get a victory
because it'll be a victory for everyone
and is more pointed out by Patrick could
be a litmus test for other challenges in
the world that's all that all the time
we have gentlemen many thanks my guests
in Raleigh Jerusalem and in Plymouth and
thanks to our viewers for watching us
here at RT see you next time and
remember crosstalk
you